pedro castillo's a 51 year old rural
primary school teacher
is now president-elect he won on the
promise he won't forget
poor peruvians how can ministers and
politicians earn such salaries when our
children have no internet our schools
are falling apart
families are begging for oxygen homes
have no water or electricity
we will rescue this country to give our
poorest families a home with dignity
he grew up in a poor family in a remote
andean village
but in 2017 castillo led a successful
nationwide teacher strike
which supporters say gave him
credentials to lead the country
in perspective i give pedro the
perspective to go forward
into a national fight we have showed we
can also govern with experience from our
towns
as mayors and governors and now the
country
previous leaders have been unable to
resolve the direst
but problems has many scared he first
told voters he'd nationalize some
industries
redistribute wealth and rewrite the
constitution
they say castillo would take away your
home your savings your land
that is completely false we have to
understand that we must put things in
order
though he stoned down his rhetoric
critics don't believe him
they say castillo and his supporters
stole the election
they won't accept the results these
people have come here to sow hatred
they've come to the capitol with their
machetes to threaten us
and we will not allow it
castillo doesn't have any criminal
record he represents the radical leftist
free pedu party whose leader convicted
for corruption
invited castillo to take his place and
now critics are afraid castillo will be
his subject
the biggest question for many here is
what will happen after pedro castillo is
sworn in on july the 28th
will he surround himself by moderates or
will he radicalize himself to the left
to keep the support of the party he
represents castillo has no government
experience
but analysts say his supporters feel
identified
he looks like most peruvians he
represents the poor the hungry and rural
teachers
teachers who suffer the most i don't
know what more one could expect from a
politician
analysis castillo's ability to govern
will hang in the balance
with nearly half of the country
rejecting him and the other half
who demands change and who will expect
nothing less from him
than to deliver on his promises mariana
sanchez
al jazida lima peru